Scot Solak was in Miami last night got
back at 6:00 a.m. this morning in Boston
he is the color commentator on the radio
for the Patriots also has a host on as a
radio host on 98.5 the Sports Hub in
Boston Scott thanks for joining us this
morning what happened last night it's
funny I get the call for the Dan Patrick
show you know eight straight wins no
calls coming infinitely linked in Miami
to get their first loss in nine games
then all of a sudden damn Patrick's
calling it's a bad spot for him you know
people have been asking me all last week
you know when it would have me on Danny
oh is this a loser Bowl game you know of
course it's a loser bowl game or like
how can I lose weight you don't have
your all world tight in you know you
don't have your right tackle dhama
consume us to kill Brady he's put that
out in black and white that's been a
thing for for two weeks now it's got him
a weird spot because it's the second
time you played the Dolphins in a matter
of three weeks and you've got to switch
a quarterback and I've only said this
about Jay Cutler I admire him because of
his athletic ability even though it's
just you know you watch a game last
night he still can't put a game together
for 60 minutes and almost had a couple
boneheaded places again but he's a
streaky thrower and you know they got
Brady off his spot last night that's
that's what you got to do you got to
move him in that pocket and make him
feel uncomfortable and you saw the look
on his face never seemed to get in any
sort of a groove and you know when you
disrupt this offense in their timing
they are beatable alright coming off a
loss going into Pittsburgh as opposed to
coming off a win how did the Patriots
prepare Bella checks mindset sort of is
there any way that this is this helps
them going into Pittsburgh in your
opinion I mean it's hard to believe that
they would come out play this this was
the same style that they did last night
and replicate that Pittsburgh
considering the type of personnel
they're going to face with Ben and what
they have on offense but you know
historically I think you know Brady's
felt pretty good about facing whether
it's a Dick LeBeau defense or you know
you see what Keith Butler's tried to do
and he said they're gonna be more
aggressive and go after him you know you
spread Pittsburgh out and I think
Pittsburgh has a difficult time covering
tight ends and the big boys back this
week he should be well
stood after his little incident up in
Buffalo and you turn them loose down
Aaron and what is it wouldn't I'd field
now right up yes look kid I'm getting
ready to call Three Rivers Stadium from
all the years back then how would you
sum up though this this team this year
when you lose Edelman to start you know
the line a little bit makeshift there
but it just feels like it doesn't matter
who Brady has on offense he somehow
makes it work but where's the defense
because that was really the big key to
start the year so the big thing is the
defense is treaded well especially over
the last six weeks
the corners are playing better week to
week Gilmore was gaining confidence last
night was not a good good night for the
corner so I didn't think Butler competed
real well on the outside Gilmore got
caught up and some stuff they didn't
have hole well Kenyan Drake ran all over
them you know and it's yeah you don't
set the edge you didn't have Trey
flowers I'm not making excuses here but
you know you're yeah you're down another
five six starters last night and facing
the division opponent on the road on a
Monday night game with a short week and
a lot of people talked about that
Pittsburgh game not saying they looked
ahead by mean hey they are a little bit
human and they have and tell you what
the end they're able to run the ball
this year with four different guys which
is pretty impressive it doesn't really
matter who's gonna tackle Brady sets the
protection but there's only so many hits
he can take you know at his age at 40
and I don't think it's 40 off he's going
wear and tear it's just you know you
don't have that woman you'd only have
Gronkowski waiting for this kid Malcolm
Mitchell to come back and Brandon cooks
was a non-factor last night again
he's got Zola who turns I think 50
tomorrow don't you come on Dan that's
right Wow it's over I'm past you now
right yes were you now 47 yeah yeah 47
again
I've been 47 for about 10 years now I
got a basketball court in there so you
work out a little bit got a golf
simulator if you want to come in you
want a piece of me come on in
I mean before is that 2 and a half from
here if you leave now we'll get you in
by the end of the show
give me the team that would concern you
and the Patriots once you get to the
postseason in the AFC I was saying this
for the last three weeks
whay Baltimore was starting to play now
the way they didn't finish that game the
other night that's a team that has come
in here and just you know they're led by
Terrell Suggs I think Dean Pease and his
defense if somehow they get in and win
it to win a wild-card game and end up
coming here divisional round at the team
that I don't feel comfortable playing
and eight we saw the Chargers earlier
this year I like Phillip Rivers always
have I think the Chargers have the best
offensive front as far as to edge guys
can go and attack the quarterback and
the pretty physical in the secondary I
think the Chargers in a way they're
trending here can be one of those teams
you don't want to face divisional round
Chargers and Baltimore the two teams I
would not want to face Jacksonville
doesn't concern you as much with the
quarterbacking situation they were here
for joint joint practices this summer
got a close look at them they're big
they're physical I think they're
building it the right way you know cod
the way Coughlin's doing it I just I
don't know if at this point you can
trust Blake bortles if he you know he
had a good week last week against
Seattle I think that was his first big
win against a really good opponent I
credit Seattle for what they've been
able to do and hang with injuries but if
he could put four of those together and
that way he's trying to coming in then
it's something to worry about but that
defense is great and in fournette is
great to like you know the defense and
running the football can usually keep
you in games and it travels well it's
just you know bortles is the x-factor
here yes yes and that's that's the one
thing you can't get him not to throw off
the back foot can you get him to play
for 60 minutes it's like Cutler last
night Cutler almost killed them at the
end of that game and almost let them
slide back into it but I don't know the
experience should carry into playoffs
and you get to quarterback now that's
seen it all
you know just the coaching matchup I
think Belichick against anybody
divisional round if you get the by what
two weeks to prepare should be should be
check mark advantage New England Scott
thanks for joining us a early happy
birthday there to you and we'll talk
down down the road in the postseason
thank you every time appreciated thanks
for having me on then Scott solak former
NFL quarterback as the Patriots color
commentator on radio very opinionated
spirited and also a talk show host in
Boston 98.5 the Sports Hub for more Dan
Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]